the conjuring stars
[Music]
yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
let's go eat ha come on let's go I'm so
sorry
the conjuring is directed by James Wan
and stars Patrick Wilson Vera Farmiga
Lily Taylor and Ron Livingston the
office space guy now the conjuring is
based on a true story that happens a lot
in Hollywood I'm not gonna delve too
deep into that because this movie is
really a story about these two people
who are paranormal investigators who are
sent to this house and the owners of
this house and their family believe that
there is something very bad going on in
this house and they are basically sent
there to debunk it and figure out what
it is and while these guys tend to go
into people's houses and say well it's
actually this broken shudder here or
that this pipe is leaking causing this
wood to expand and creak and it's not
actually a ghost over time they realize
that in fact something not very good is
going on in this house now James Wan is
one of my favorite horror directors he
is a guy who really understands how to
build tension and suspense and he also
makes a really good-looking movie -
insidious look great and I like how he
uses real props and makeup and
prosthetics to create scares and not a
whole bunch of CGI I really love how he
uses minimal CGI and really just tries
to build tension out of scene
construction and the conjuring proves
that he can still do that very well this
movie was very suspenseful all the way
through it kept me on the edge as I
watched it it was a film that all those
slow building and possibly a little too
slow-paced to start really picked up as
it went along and the scares continue to
get more intense to the point where it
wasn't just all thrown at your face in
the beginning you know as the movie
progressed you were able to get more
into it be able to experience more
frightening elements to the movie and
the thing that I really liked about
James wanted the way he constructs his
films is that he doesn't fake scares he
earns all of his scares in his films he
doesn't do the stupid oh I'm actually
behind you right now or oh there's a
bird flying out of a shudder oh my god a
cat just jumped out of the cupboard like
he doesn't do any stupid scares like
that all of his scares are meaningful
and even when there are moments
throughout the movie where there's a
false scare he never uses stupid jump
loud music to do that and I really
really liked that about the way he stood
up this
because when you go to a scary movie
there's a certain thing you have to
expect and that is to be scared and a
lot of times the way I critique scary
films is how did the director build his
scares
how does he present his scares and
really what James Wan did really well
with the conjuring is create an
atmosphere that was just really creepy
and that is what he is very good at
doing he uses creepy doll faces and
puppets and odd images and sounds and
really good performances especially from
Patrick Wilson and Vera Farmiga they
were both fantastic in this movie I
thought they gave really great
performances and you could tell that
they were really invested in this very
otherworldly story and I really like
when actors just throw their all into a
story and help it be way more believable
than it would have been if these actors
wouldn't have done that
Lily Taylor is also very good in this
movie as this distressed mother who's
experiencing all these events she's very
good at portraying this protective vibe
for her family but at the same time
she's really good towards the latter
half of the film where stuff really
starts to hit the fan and I'm not gonna
get into that but she just she gave a
really good performance in this movie
and I was really impressed with her run
Livingston's character is actually one
of my biggest flaws with this movie he
wasn't bad he was just fine as his
character but it was like the most
underdeveloped cardboard cutout father
ever like he really didn't have much to
do in this movie he was just sort of
there to be the father his character was
very underdeveloped you didn't learn
hardly anything about him really but my
main flaw with this movie actually isn't
a flaw with this movie I can't downgrade
the movie because of my least favorite
thing about it it's actually the
marketing's fault
unfortunately I saw a couple of trailers
for this movie and having seen the film
I can say that I knew almost every scare
for the first half of this movie which
was very very depressing to me because
each time I was like oh pan up show it
pan over there it's there look behind
you it's there right now simply because
I saw the trailer and I wasn't expecting
to have all those scare spoiled for me
the last half of the movie was like not
in the trailer at all I was very happy
about that the first half very much so
spoiled in those trailers I'm not gonna
downgrade the film because of that
because it's not the film's fault it's
the marketing and I'm very very pissed
about that to be honest that was very
annoying to me because seriously you
guys ruined like the first half of the
scares in this movie they were all
expected and I really was not happy
about that however I can see
that if you watch this movie or if I had
watched this movie not having seen those
trailers I would have been very much so
on the edge of my seat at some of those
moments but the moments that did keep me
on the edge were the moments leading up
to these things that were in the
trailers the suspense was handled very
well the tension was excellent he did a
great job with his cinematography as I
said the performances were really good
the movie is a little bit slow building
at times and it does feel familiar like
you've seen these elements before this
isn't like a reinvention of the genre
you're gonna see him again in other
movies too
but it was all handled very well and I
really liked that about the conjuring
I'm gonna give the conjuring a B+ I
think it's a very strong horror film I
think that if you're going into it for a
scare you'll get that hopefully you
didn't watch any of the trailers though
James Wan is really becoming good at
what he does I hope insidious 2 is good
as well it's coming out soon as always
guys thanks for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mini heist
[Music]